[Music]
it's a snackable version of the what
podcast today barry corder lord taco
brad you can you can call me brad so uh
this is uh we call it a snackable
version of the what podcast because you
guys had some chats during bonnaroo with
some of our uh favorite bonnaroo axe huh
yeah yeah we
called it
i thought you called it a snackable
version because i'm a snack again
taco so yummy yes
who doesn't want to put their face in a
taco
yeah
yeah i know you know as we've said
before part of the fun for us at being
on the farm is uh being able to
interview some of these bands that uh
that we've either learned about or are
big fans of um
do you remember the time years ago we
were supposed to uh i can't remember was
it alt j
and uh we were like i don't remember
what happened but it was either really
hot or we were really tired and we were
like
you know what all jay's like 20 feet
away from us
we're not going to be doing that today
yeah we're not doing that
yeah got a pass it would require us to
walk oh i don't know a whole 20 yards uh
we can't do it yeah it gets way way over
there
and you know we we had the other one
that we talked about all the time where
we had to go find a cigarette for the
guy the thing we don't mention but no we
don't talk about we don't talk about
bossy around here yeah we don't talk
about bossy but then we've had the
warren treaty moments where we just fell
in love yeah you know and again that was
another one of those that i would have
very easily punted on if you gave me the
opportunity if you give me the
opportunity the opening to cancel i'm
going to take it because i just i i'd
rather just sit at camp
well
i'm not going to lie
back seat lovers who were going to talk
to and churches were back-to-back for us
they were within half hour of each other
and um
i think we went to see back seat lovers
and then like idiots didn't bring the
equipment with us
and leave it in the media areas so we
had to run from there all the way back
you know way away okay yeah see this is
such a what is like there's always a
comedy of problems when it comes to this
group something stupid happens like for
instance in today's chat
you just decided not to record it with
preston maroney did you
yeah yeah i did everything right uh
except hit the little red button it
turns out it turns out the first rule in
radio is you got to turn the microphone
on
it didn't happen
to add on to that you know i i did the
video recording i recorded the first
interview fine
then we redid it because barry didn't
hit record so i hit record and then like
40 seconds in it stops recording so yeah
we've got
one full video and one full audio but
it's two takes
i fully look i i totally believe that
the reason why um things screw up even
if i'm not there or because of me
i'm i'm sure it's my fault
you know
yeah your name came up
i've broken every piece of lawn
equipment i've ever been given
uh i'm good i said yeah break everything
we do here yeah you know it's usually
destroyed dressing rooms
i had to laugh too because
when we were interviewing churches they
were drinking the what is that toppo
cheese
yeah
i just laughing to myself remembering
that incident yeah i actually i don't
remember if you remember taco too with
the bristol before we even started and
maybe it's why i forgot to hit record is
my battery pack the sun fried it
yeah it was not working yeah we couldn't
get anything to turn on because it had
been so hot
i guess sitting in my car
so fortunately plus had a backup battery
pack or we would have not had it at all
so yeah i remembered to bring extras
yeah bring everything that's the number
one rule uh yeah i have a dollar
i bring nothing
you bring nothing and then blame yeah
that way you're uh you're you know
somebody else's fault hey i didn't break
it
somebody else did it
it's not mine
it ended up
it ended up being great those are really
one of my favorite things to do
is to talk to these guys and
and they were all very receptive and
their management people made it work and
you were making it work from new york
that was kind of funny would you that
sent the text or was it churches or
backseat you're like i'm at i'm at
dinner with their manager yeah
here set it up
yeah i know i was i was we uh i'll talk
about that when we um do the uh the baxi
lovers uh chat but uh the one we start
with today
um bristol moroni you hit play thank
goodness because you know the kid's got
a great story and uh the only reason i
even know him
or know of him is because one of my
interns when i was a uh when i was in
chattanooga
uh randomly she's a fanta i mean she's a
superstar this girl i think that they
dated when they were like in middle
school and she would she would always
sit in the studio and this is like 10
years ago and she'd be like i've got
this friend briston he's a really good
singer you know every time he's like
okay sure you do everybody's got the
right the buddy with a gig everybody's
got the friend of the gig
and uh she just kept talking about him
talking about him then one day i found
him he was on one of my playlists on
spotify i was like wait a second
this kid's actually
actually a thing
he's really good he's really really good
uh and he's just one of these that you
know matt mason types that you know he's
going to write a good song not a good
song you know he's going to write these
songs sooner or later and it's going to
you know blow up and we're all going to
be like hey
it's that guy again
yeah
he was so sweet it was a great interview
uh i'm i'm looking forward which one the
first one or the second one
um
it was good both were good
uh the you know unfortunately the first
one was a little more uh off the cuff
but we still got he talked about his
father which was amazing because it was
father's day weekend
um
and he talked about the wristband which
i thought was kind of funny um what
wristband like the bonnaroo wristband
yeah the bonnery wristband why was that
come on
well he because in the course of the
conversation uh you know he's he's a
knoxville kid so obviously he's aware of
bonnaroo and i think i said you know
what did you know about it and he he
just said all the kids would come back
to high school with their suntans and
their wristbands oh that's good and
my
my daughter's friends when they went um
i think they wore those wristbands until
they literally fell off their wrists
i mean years so i asked him about that
let me tell you something i actually
there's so i'm glad you brought that up
because one day
uh we were eating i don't know what the
restaurant was but we we sit down and
the guy that's taking our our order
he goes uh hey blah blah blah blah and i
noticed the wristband that he's still
wearing from bonnaroo i'm like oh you
went to bonnard that's great and then he
pulls the rest of his shirt up and he's
got like three years of bands on his arm
and i immediately looked do you know
where i'm going with this barry you know
me
i literally looked across the table to
the wife and i said we gotta go
this guy is going to be touching our
plate i can't have this disgusting thing
interacting with my food that's
horrifying to me
it's pretty it's pretty nasty because i
know you guys i'm sure you're the same
when you get home
it's you know it's like when somebody
loses a limb they say they can still
feel it you know you cut that thing off
your wrist and you feel it for the next
week or two well you know my you know my
strategy with the wristband i keep it so
loose that i take it off every night it
drives me bananas i hate the thing and i
cannot stand it i wish there was a way
that we could like figure out a
different way than than using these
wristbands because i just i hate i don't
even wear wrist watches i hate watches i
don't like things around my neck or my
wrists um so yeah
i'm i'm with you
i figured out if you if you if you don't
tighten it and use a rubber band to sort
of knot it up it won't fall off during
the day yeah then you can take it off at
night or whatever yeah plus there's all
those years where we were like
especially the first two three years
where we were like using other people's
cut wristbands before they sort of got
smart to it and figured out that uh yeah
why don't we just start tracking these
people as they walk in and out of here
so that uh
you know my very first one
um i
i left sunday as i did this year but i
left and stopped at that gas station and
a guy
offered to buy it from me and i was like
no i'm not gonna do it they've been good
to me that's not right and as i drove
off i thought man that guy looked like a
cop he was a narc
that you know
it was not a long-haired hippie it
looked like it looked like an fbi guy
and i said man i'm glad i didn't i mean
tell that thing to him that's pretty
ironic considering you are the cop in
the group i know he came up to me right
that's he probably figured the old man's
leaving this goes you know he didn't
want to be there yeah
but briston was great and uh it's it i i
heard uh nothing but
good things from all kinds of people i
think he's in a lot of you know people
when they list their top shows he's he's
he's on a lot of lists that's great
nice kid so so nice and and he was a you
know he's been a guest on our show
before
this was his second and third interviews
with us yeah i was gonna say um
other than i'm trying to think i want to
do the big board of the guests that
we've had on who has come back twice who
of course repeat repeat are well in the
lead they they're the gold standard when
it comes to guests on the show uh jeff
cuellar is probably
second with
three appearances at least three we got
can lions sit on two
yeah and then who else is in the in the
double double appearance category
i don't know i know we have bristol
moroni might be the only other one we
all we only have four return guests
no no um
uh was aaron the guy who won the tickets
this year
he was a patriot oh yeah
david grimes david grimes i guess i
guess you're right we could we could
throw in
you know the the ham babies and the
rubus is in multiple guests but i don't
i don't count them i guess for some odd
reason i don't know why they've been on
multiple times yeah sure
but as far as uh performers or or
like quayle uh you know what if i get it
this is the problem if i include the
rubus in the in the hams kids that means
i gotta include a brian stone and i just
can't put him
i wonder if you were gonna go there
multiple guest appearances yeah i
wondered if you were gonna go there yeah
yeah stones are repeat repeat offender
oh god all right well let's do it uh
let's start the first of uh many
snackable episodes coming from this
year's bonnaroo with bristol moroni on
the what podcast
[Music]
hey everybody we are at bonnaroo you can
hear the music playing in the background
i'm barry corter with the what podcast
with me lord taco as always and we have
a special guest hello a repeat guest
uh three-time a three-time earner
technically three-timer yeah the
trifecta we might have had some
technical issues but we're not going to
get into that bristol moroni is here
great to see you again thank you again
anytime dude for talking to us you were
a guest on our show
a few weeks ago one of our favorite
guests oh thank you and we have had you
on the list of wish lists the people we
wanted to talk to when we were here oh
thanks thank you for making it happen
anytime dude
tell me about
bonnaroo and what it means to you to
play this festival yeah i mean i think
the biggest thing
is just like the history of this
festival
within
being a tennessee native uh and just
being a kid who grew up loving
just like specifically rock music but
all types of music it just embodies
just like
what a music festival
is inside of my brain it was when i was
a child too you know
yeah you i think you said off the air um
that you knew of it from
[Music]
high school yes talking about your kids
would come back oh yes there was the one
dude i i
i won't say his name just for
for uh what's the word posterity sick
but uh yeah he was the festival guy and
he would come back one thing i didn't
mention last time
was that i was most envious of his uh
tan line that came from the wristband so
yeah that dude rocked his wristband from
bonnaroo for like seven years or
something he was the kid who would go
when we were like 12
and i was still like
just like eating gogurt at my house like
playing gamecube and he was out like
crowd surfing at fish and i was nice
nice nice
it's uh it's father's day weekend and
you've got a special guest here this
year right yeah oh yeah yeah my pops got
to come out and
uh he's been able to come to some more
shows in the past few months than ever
before and
this was this was a big one for us um
yeah i'm really stoked man yeah what
does it mean having him there for you
uh i
i think
the biggest thing you know that
we were hitting on is just that
the fact that there there's an audience
there to see this music is is very
special very beautiful but
uh
we were saying that if all that was
stripped away knowing that that he was
there
would be
equally as impactful and equally as
special to me more than anything yeah
there's your happy father's day happy
father's day pops
that's really cool yeah um i know you're
busy you've got a lot of other
interviews uh what what's coming up what
else besides this when you leave here
we're working on new music that'll be
out in the next few weeks uh we're about
to
do a little run kind of zig zaggy with
rainbow kitten surprise
um which i'm i'm really excited about uh
and then we're doing some headlining
shows in the fall in september so very
cool yeah man i said it before on the
show
and i'll say it here
we really think big things are in store
for you thank you man that's so kind you
guys are so sweet yeah well we mean it i
mean
we've done this too long to lie and
we're not very good at it
i think that's the best the best trait
to have is being a bad liar
thank you so much yeah thank you guys
man all right absolutely
[Music]
okay kids uh there you go uh bristol
maroney anything uh to follow up
anything else before we go
no it's just so nice to hear him talk
about his dad and uh i mean the idea
that if the entire rest of the audience
went away and it was just his dad out
there he would still be happy barry are
we not telling you we love you enough
no are you no
no are you never is dad not getting
fishing is dad not getting enough
attention
i got i got some i felt the love from
briston so it meant a lot to me what
about brad guy
i had to fish for it i had to fish for
it
no it was just neat to hear that kind of
i mean that was completely unsolicited
and it was really cool to hear him say
it yeah that's great though all right
well yeah nice kid and i can't i i wish
nothing but the best for him yeah and
it's super nice of him to redo it after
we yeah
he's very gracious yeah
you know i think hasn't there that's
happened to us before who else have we
done two interviews with we had to
completely start over and we ended up
not even using it because ah this sucked
yeah yeah yeah who was that i don't even
remember i don't remember
i know what you're talking about but i
don't remember i think i i think i do
remember and i will not repeat the uh
the band's name because they might be on
the episode on an episode very soon i uh
i don't wanna remind them of that
disaster
yeah we played it i promise no we aired
it uh it's uh we must have gotten lost
in the archives
oh it was one of our favorites yeah best
episodes
all right uh that wraps it up for us
another snack pool episode uh coming at
you next
[Music]
consequence podcast network